today i am announcing that next season
season 19 is going to be my last season
and now that time has come as ellen
degeneres officially says goodbye to her
talk show i love what i do i love making
people happy and i love seeing people
laugh and have a good time
and she did it to the very end ellen
sharing this smiling snapshot announcing
she just taped the final episode of her
talk show in a series of tweets ellen
reflects on her nearly two decade long
gig writing quote when we started this
show in 2003 the iphone didn't exist
social media didn't exist gay marriage
wasn't legal we watched the world change
sometimes for the better sometimes not
adding my goal was always for the show
to be a place where we could all come
together and laugh for an hour being
invited into your lives has been the
greatest privilege of my life and has
brought me incredible joy thank you
thank you thank you you know it's the
greatest thing fans will have to wait a
minute to see ellen's final show it
doesn't air until may 26th which is
nearly a year after the comedian
emotionally revealed she was ending the
hit talker my instinct told me it's time
as a comedian i have always understood
the importance of
timing and
in all seriousness i truly have felt
like next season was the right time to
end this amazing chapter the past 18
years
you have to know has changed my life
you
all have changed my life and i am
forever grateful to all of you for
watching
for laughing for dancing sometimes
crying
this show has been the greatest
experience of my life
and i owe it all to you
someone who's been along for the ride is
stephen twitch boss he started popping
up as ellen's dj sidekick in 2014 and
told e.t earlier this year he totally
understood ellen's decision to call it
quits i've been at the show in the
capacity that i'm in now for almost nine
years wow
and then i mean listen ellen's been at
it for 19 years and
for and for those reasons it is time
things do have a beginning and they have
an end so i know that but i think the
closer that it's getting to the end yeah
naturally as we do you start to miss it
and you and you and you start to soak in
all of the little moments where you go
well maybe i'm not quite ready to say
goodbye just yet but then at the same
time this is the natural order of things
and i'm also i've said it before i'm
just excited for my friend to start her
new chapter of her of her the rest of
her journey before that new chapter
begins ellen is closing out this chapter
with some fan favorite guests with her
many special guests like longtime friend
adam levine
first of all i love you you know that
but this is your 26th time on the show
and you were here almost every single
season since season one we've had you
every single season
and oprah winfrey who knows a thing or
two about leaving daytime behind i think
you will miss the camaraderie of the
audience but you also are out in the
world you know if you choose to do
stand-up or not do stand-up you get some
of that um
feeling of that resonance from an
audience so i miss the audience the most
yeah and twitch he knows this won't be
the last you see of ellen she's not
going away it's just
this saga the of the ellen degeneres
talk show this one is coming to a close
but ellen degeneres is ellen degeneres
[Music]